[Music]
we have won the great war
now we will win the last wall
we'll rip her out root and stem
[Music]
we hope to kind of avoid the expected
and jon snow has always been the hero
the one who's
in the savior but it just didn't seem
right to us for this for this moment
we knew it had to be valerian steel to
the exact spot where the
child of the forest put the dragonglass
blade to create the night king
and he's uncreated by the valyrian steel
at the end of it it's it's still it's a
it's a victory for the living but
at great cost because some of our
favorite characters fall
along the way hi everyone it's charlie
this is going to be my game of thrones
season 8 episode 4
trailer video talking about the next big
war is daenerys is calling it during the
trailer the last war
there's still so much stuff going on
we've got the game of thrones prequel
that's coming up too so be sure to
subscribe to get all the game of thrones
videos i know there are a lot of
questions after last night's episode
there are a couple more bonus videos
that i have planned about that but i'm
also doing the q a video
and there's a new round of that hbo now
giveaway too all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
obviously careful for spoilers for
everything through episode three
so here we go we'll just start with the
footage so this very daenerys and cersei
centric trailer is all daenerys voice
over from a couple different speeches or
maybe just one speech broken up into a
couple different pieces
because there's only one part of the
trailer where you actually see her
speaking the words
but it's all about the aftermath and
them sort of cleaning up the battlefield
you see them burning the bodies in here
too it's gonna stink to high heaven
around winterfell
until all those bodies are gone the
whole idea here is daenerys says
we won the great war as they talked
about the war against the nike and the
white walkers now we will win the last
war and she's absolutely determined
she even puts herself in a very deep
targaryen red
dress which is interesting because
cersei is also wearing a very deep red
dress
without listening to the costume
designer explain why she made those
choices why those colors in particular
because targaryens do wear red so it's
not unusual for daenerys to wear a red
dress
but it is kind of interesting that she
wears red because it's the color of
blood
even though house targaryen's motto is
fire and blood
right after the battle of winterfell
when they shed all that blood because
you basically lost all of the dothraki
there's still dothraki in the east that
did not side with daenerys and come over
it's really just her blood riders that
she lost
but they're completely gone they lost
most of their forces most of the
unsullied as well
usually after something like that you
wear black which is also a targaryen
color because you're in mourning for all
the people that you lost
like she'd be in mourning for sir jorah
because she cared about him so much even
though it wasn't actual romantic love
you see her in the red dress toasting
everyone in the great hall
because they're obviously really excited
that they all survived they finally won
the war
now it's time to get ready for the next
one you could draw all kinds of
metaphors about the red wedding
arya's reverse red wedding all the red
blood that they're going to be shedding
during the last war which it seems like
might be most of episode 5 although i
don't think the battle will be quite as
big as the battle of winterfell just in
terms of a production
biggest difference in the next big
battle is it'll probably take place
during daytime hopefully so you'll
actually be able to see what's going on
and because of that geographically it'll
be much easier to place yourself whereas
it seemed like the battle of winterfell
was the biggest that the show had ever
done
it may have actually taken place over a
much smaller area because winterfell
even though it's a huge castle
isn't nearly as big as the red keep in
king's landing daenerys says they'll rip
cersei out root and stem i guess that
she's the root and euron is the stem
because it seems like euron is proposing
to her
in this trailer and she'll probably wind
up accepting because even if she doesn't
like him that much
she still needs his help so she needs to
keep that alliance intact so as stannis
baratheon would say
go ahead do your duty like when he was
talking to brienne he knew what was
about to happen and even though it
wasn't going to be pleasant he knew that
it had to go down that way cersei's
backed herself into a corner and now
she's doing
everything she can to keep her house of
cards from collapsing
you get a really good shot of the
smoldering remains of winterfell
post-battle the next morning
like i said they'll probably reflect
this in the opening credits cersei and
euron looking down at the commoners in
king's landing walking around in the
square
giving you a really big look at the
front gate that'll be important for the
next big battle episode
like they did for winterfell they built
all these new kings landing sets because
they're going to be using them way more
than they have in previous seasons
most of their king's landing city shots
are filmed in and around dubrovnik and
croatia but a lot of the big battle
stuff that they're getting ready to film
at king's landing they filmed on their
titanics that they had to build special
sets just because of what they're doing
during the battle
we don't know exactly how the battle is
going to go down but we do have a broad
idea and we know finally we're going to
get to see the golden company in action
you see sansa watching the northerners
as they clean up the battlefield and
start to repair the worst damage to
winterfell
it's going to take them a long time to
rebuild winterfell but it's not nearly
as destroyed as i expected it to be
i knew that some of the castle would be
left but when you saw the night king use
viserion to just
plow right through one of the walls
towards the end of the episode i
expected a lot more of that but viserion
did spend
like the last at least 10 minutes of the
episode just breathing blue flame all
over the courtyard
the weird thing about the way they cut
the trailer too is it seems like
everyone is headed down to king's
landing on daenerys ships eventually but
based on the misleading way that they
cut this it seems like sansa might not
go back to king's landing with them
which would be interesting because she
did vow a long time ago never to go back
just because her time was joffrey with
the lannisters was so
bad she never ever wanted to return so
you guys can let me know in the comments
just assuming that this trailer is
misleading do you think that sansa
actually will go back to king's landing
before the end of the season
because remember even though we have
this episode 5 big battle coming up
we don't know exactly everything they're
going to be doing during the finale and
the finale is going to be one of their
longest episodes ever
you see daenerys walking around the
halls of winterfell in that deep red
dress
you see regal fly over daenerys's ships
as they're sailing for king's landing
you also see rhaegal and drogon flying
over sansa
standing on the battlements of
winterfell so confirmed to both be alive
and well none the worst for wear and a
lot of people were wondering what
happened to rhaegal after he and jon
snow went down
it seemed like he was still alive and
unless you see a body you can't really
say yes or no
because there have been a couple deaths
that happened off-screen summer
sacrificed himself to allow them to get
away you didn't exactly see him die so
it seemed like it happened off-screen so
i think everybody was kind of worried
especially until we saw
ghost in this trailer too very good boy
who also shows up outside
that we didn't know whether or not they
killed him off screen too because he ran
to the assault with the dothraki and
sergio at the beginning of the episode
but you never really saw him come back
so everyone was just kind of crossing
their fingers
speaking of which i don't think that
ghosts would be down for carrion or the
dragons either there still is food for
them to eat up there now that they have
maybe a fraction of their troops
it's not like they're going to run out
of their food faster they haven't
actually taken a head count yet either
for those of you that are asking how
many of their troops are left
but you get shots of sansa arya jon snow
the rest of the survivors standing
outside while we're getting that
daenerys voice over which is probably
coming from a different scene
you see daenerys speaking the second
part of her quote though talking about
ripping cersei out rudin's stem
inside their planning room there so
maybe that whole speech just comes from
this one scene
there's a scene of daenerys checking on
drogon i love the look on his face it's
almost like he's smiling a big dragon
toothy smile at something but because
daenerys is looking up in the sky
they're both probably looking at regal
and maybe
john on rhaegal so she's probably just
relieved that both of her children are
still alive
there's the scene of arya kissing gendry
later that night it'll be interesting to
see now that the survivors have sort of
found each other and they're starting to
clean things up
how much post-battle sex happens during
this episode
a lot of you remember that robert
baratheon quote from season one in the
pilot when he said i have a son
you have a daughter to ned stark let's
get them together well you can actually
still do that with arya and gendry now
depending on how you think they wind up
it'll be funny to see how cersei reacts
to gendry if they wind up in a scene
together knowing that one of robert's
bastards still exists out there
there's a scene of jon snow and davos
riding out the front gate of winterfell
with gilly watching behind them in the
courtyard
then they end the trailer with a shot of
cersei euron and the mountain outside
looking over something maybe either
watching daenerys's ships roll in or
maybe just watching the people of king's
landing go about their business while
they plan
for the next big attack but either way
the whole trailer is just meant to give
you the
aftermath of the battle of winterfell in
the preparation for the battle against
cersei so like i said i think the actual
battle won't happen till episode five
but we'll see daenerys's ships rolling
up to king's landing at the end of
episode four
episode four is only supposed to be 78
minutes long so it's about 4 minutes
shorter than episode 3 but episode 5
and the finale episode 6 are both going
to be 80 minutes long so the last couple
of episodes are actually pretty close in
length but those episode links also
include the little intro the episode
recap that they attached to beginning of
episodes they do not include the promos
that they attached to the end of the
episodes because if you watch them on
hbo now they'll just roll from the
episode into the bonus featurettes and
stuff so it seems like it's all part of
the episode but really it's not
i know a lot of you are still sort of
reeling about the swerves or the seeming
swerves on the prophecies azor ahai
because of arya killing the night king
during episode three there's actually a
video that i have planned for that later
this week because there was a very
interesting original plan that george r
martin had for song of ice and fire
before he changed there was going to be
a big
time jump so a lot of the younger
characters like arya sansa
jon snow by the time this stuff was
happening in the song of ice and fire
originally it was planned that they
would be much much older
but he wound up cancelling those plans
things went down a little bit
differently but the main players were
largely still the same
although a lot of the plot machinations
and character relationships wound up
changing like originally there was going
to be an arya love triangle with jon
snow in tyrion
in the original outline that he had so
just give you an idea for how
different his original plan for game of
thrones was there's so much other stuff
happening this week that video probably
won't post till wednesday or thursday
but i will also be doing a q a video
just like i've done for previous
episodes
but when it comes to azor ahai there are
still a couple of twists that i'm
expecting that could fulfill the
prophecy
just in a way that you're not expecting
like dan and dave say during that
featurette where it was really important
for them not to play to people's
expectations
even though that jon has been the main
hero thus far
they didn't want him to be the one to
kill the night king so i will try to
address
how much of that i think was part of
george rr martin's plan that he gave to
dan and dave when they were plotting out
the rest of the series because a lot of
the big
beats are based on what martin told them
and martin actually even recently did
talk about how much his
ending would be similar to what they're
doing on the show so i'll talk about
some of the differences that he
discussed and some of the similarities
because you will be surprised by how
much of it will be similar to the way
the dream of spring and winds of winter
is supposed to go down
but a lot of the big differences too
especially thematic differences by the
end of the finale we'll be talking about
after we get episode six but if there
are any big videos that you guys want me
to do about all this let me know in the
comments
congratulations to the last big giveaway
winner bruno carhoni please email me on
the about page of my channel so i can
get your details
while you wait for everything click here
for my episode 3 video and click here
for my episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight